- [David] Hello grammarians, hello Rosie!
- [Rosie] Hi David!
- [David] So, You've
caught me mid-scribble
in the greatest challenge of my career.
Will I be able to write
the word ono-mato-poeia?
- [Rosie] You can do it.
- [David] Did I get it?
- [Rosie] You did it.
- [David] Yes!
This is one of my least
favorite words to spell
but one of my favorite
things to talk about.
Because what we're talking about today is
alliteration, assonance,
and onomatopoeia.
And these are all words that are related
to the way language sounds.
But let's begin with alliteration.
Rosie, what is alliteration?
- [Rosie] Alliteration
is when a series of words
all start with the same consonant.
- [David] So what's a
good example of that?
- [Rosie] Robert Park
swam swiftly, surely,
and straight ahead.
- [David] So you can see that
all these pink words here,
swam, swiftly, surely, straight
ahead, all begin with "S."
And so this is why we
call this alliteration
because "S" is a consonant and all
of these things share a
similar consonant sound.
Now I want to contrast
that with assonance,
which is what, Rosie?
- [Rosie] Assonance is
when a series of words
all start with the same vowel.
Althea abolished all anguish.
- [David] So you can
see, all of these words
in the sentence in the
same vowel neighborhood.
- [Rosie] Right.
- [David] But my favorite
of all is onomatopoeia,
which comes from Greek, and
it basically means, like,
onom, onomat, means a
name resulting from doing.
So really, this is, this word just means
sounds like what it does.
So any, really anything
that you would conceive of
as a sound effect, like a word that comes
from a sound effect.
So, the bees buzzed, for example.
Like, what is buzzed?
Well, it's the sound that a bee makes.
It's what it does.
But that word is derived
from the buzz sound.
But that's not the only
example of onomatopoeia.
We've compiled here a list.
What have we got, Rosie?
- [Rosie] Okay, we've got splat.
That's kind of the sound of
something hitting pavement.
- [David] Splat.
- [Rosie] Yep.
We've got clang, which
is like the clanging
of a bell.
We've got bang, which sounds
like something exploding.
Whoosh, which sounds like air or wind.
Beep.
- [David] Yeah.
- [Rosie] Beep sounds like a beeping.
(laughs)
- [David] Like that is
literally, so if you, if you are
trying to summon up the
actual sound of a thing
and transcribe it and use
it as a noun or a verb,
you're using onomatopoeia.
I know it's a terrifying
looking word, right?
Like, no one word should have
this many vowels in front
of the other.
I get it, I get it.
I'm, I'm terrified of spelling this word,
but I managed to do it,
apparently, and now you know
what it means, and that should take away
some of its scariness and
impart to you some of its power.
Because here at Khan Academy, we want you
to have the power to harness language,
and specifically, today,
to harness these three
different language styles.
So, alliteration, repeating
the same consonant
a bunch of times in a row,
so swimming, swiftly,
surely, and straight ahead.
- [Rosie] Assonance, where
you repeat the same vowel,
like abolished all anguish.
- [David] And onomatopoeia,
where you make a word
that sounds like what
the word's effect is.
So the bees buzzed, the
pudding cup went splat,
the boxing bell fell to
the floor with a clang,
the firework went off with
a bang, a flight of bats
whooshed past my head, and the robot,
the little baby robot
beeped at me, insistently.
- [Rosie] I like those.
- [David] How can a robot be a baby?
- [Rosie] I think it's
just the size, right?
- [David] Okay, sure.
- [Rosie] Not the age.
- [David] Okay, sure,
yeah that's legitimate.
So okay, I guess the
question is now you know
what these things are, but Rosie,
why would a person want
to use these techniques
in language, whether written or spoken?
- [Rosie] That's a great question.
Writers can use some of these techniques
to basically use the sound.
To get across a pattern.
- [David] Um-hum.
- [Rosie] Like if your going to use words
that all sound the same at the beginning,
with a bunch of "Ss" that kind of,
could potentially build some
momentum to your sentence.
Like, it kind of makes the
reader sit up and pay attention,
too, like oh, this is
an interesting pattern.
So that could be one reason
why a writer might use,
for example, alliteration.
- [David] Yeah, so it's a
way to express a pattern
and to build on what you were saying,
you can also, it's just
a good attention grabber,
and it's also useful for it's own sake,
just as a technique for
writing prose or poetry.
Like, it's something,
it's a useful property
of language to be able
to sometimes access.
- [Rosie] Right, and a good
example with onomatopoeia,
ono-mato-poeia, is
you're really capturing,
you're really capturing
the sound, so the reader
is really able to be
emersed in the experience
even more fully.
You can hear the sounds
that are happening.
The buzzing of the bees, or, yeah.
It just puts you even more in the story
that the writer's telling.
- [David] That's why you
would want to learn how to use
assonance, alliteration, and onomatopoeia.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Rosie] Rosie out.